and
welcome to our expert webinar upskilling
and reskilling strategies to create
future proof careers our guest today is
animal santa
director of learning and development cgi
um we're sponsored today by freshers
world
and we'll be live streaming both on
simplylearn and freshers world channels
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
and before we start a little
housekeeping
here's how you participate in the
webinar
the q a button with the question mark
allows you to
enter questions for annel which we will
take at the q a portion of the webinar
at the end
so please use that for any questions you
want to ask
remember to hit send the chat button
please use all panelists to send a
message to us
if you send it to host only we may not
see it
and let's
get started i'm going to start with a
poll
and to do that i will stop sharing for a
moment
the poll is very simple um
basically what is your job role and
how do you feel today
and we'll launch the poll there are a
lot of other options besides what's
on this pole
there we go
here we are
we'll give you about another
45 seconds to answer the poll
and the rating scale for how you're
feeling today is thumbs up or thumbs
down
or in the middle
and
you have about 15 seconds to put your
answers in
uh three two one
and here are the poll results
so today
we have
most people are feeling okay today and
the largest
group of uh people answering are
other professional so
with that i'm going to go back and
introduce ono
and he is the director of learning and
development at cgi
he uh has won the learning and practice
award
in 27 and 2018 from chief learning
officer magazine
he has a broad and varied career
that spans a number of companies from
western union all the way up to cgi so
we're very pleased to have him here
today and
i know i'll let you take it away
thank you thanks thanks a lot sword can
you hear me well
yes we can thank you uh
good evening and good morning everyone
depending on wherever you're joining
from in the world
it was very interesting to see the
response
40 of you said other professionals so is
it okay if
you could go to chat and share details
of
what did you mean when you say other
professions what do you do you quickly
take five seconds
and it would help me relate better to
each one of you so
and just go to the chat and share
and in the meantime i'll share my screen
[Music]
so that you can get started
your risk and governance attitude
trainer
just in transition or very interested me
project management professional
senior software engineer
assistant packing professional technical
support
engineer excellent so we have people
from all walks of life
pmp excellent
excellent health care wow
electronics engineer mechanical engineer
brilliant
so so stuart i'll get started and then
um enough
from a help with chat and q a will i get
support with q a but
i'll try to toggle in between that yeah
yeah we'll need to look at the q a
because we do have someone who is
logging the responses for uh later on
okay perfect yeah thank you thanks
so so really happy to be here to spend
next uh 45 50 minutes with all of you
and share some insights around
upskilling and reskilling strategies to
create future proof
careers and and it it's a lot worthy so
we will see how that goes
so um anyone on today's call
can identify whose picture is this
anyone
any guesses
and there's an interesting story related
to to the picture too
um yeah i see some comments saying not
sure
um wow gotham i think you got it right
the first woman who crossed
who swim the english channel uh kudos to
you got them so
so here is the image of picture of
florence chadwick
you know born in 1999 she was the first
woman to swim across the english channel
and there's an interesting story about
her and i would like to start today's
session
with her story um in you know in 1950s
when she crossed the english channel the
first woman to swim across english
channel
and on july 4th 1952 she attempted
something even more brilliant she
she tried to swim across from catalina
island to
l.a which is a 25 miles of stretch
um you know in a cold winter night
and it was a 25 miles of stretch and she
actually swam
for 15 hours all through the night she
was swimming through 15 hours
and right there to support her on on a
live boat
was her coach and her father and her
father actually carried a rifle in his
hand
to kind of scare away shots because
there were actually sharks
in the water so so after you know a
long 15 hours of swim in 25 miles
in this cold winter night
florence was almost half a mile close to
the
to the to her destination to reach the
l.a the other side of the shore and as
she started getting really close to it
like half a mile even even a lot closer
she suddenly waves her hand up in the
air and says
i'm giving up i can't do this any longer
pull me into the boat
so our father and coach absolutely
surprised
double check with her saying are you
really sure and she says yes just pull
me out
i can't do this any longer and then they
pull her out
and long story short fast forward the
next day when they were interviewing her
they asked her you swam for all 15 hours
and you're just half a mile away from
your goal your destination
why did you pull yourself out in the
last leg of your
swim florence
broke down in tears and she started
crying she said
i couldn't see my goal it was really
foggy
and and there lies very interesting
moral of the story
your goal can be really near your goal
can be really far but
now when there's fog when there's blur
which is blocking your view
you actually can't see your goal and
that's when you tend to get distracted
from your goal
and give up so if she cried and said if
my dad and my
coach told me i was just half melt away
i would pull
every ounce of my energy and swim
through i could do it but no one told me
and all i saw was fog therefore i gave
up
i thought i would start with that story
today because
as we speak all of us collectively
are going through a similar fog kind of
fog
you know with the covet affecting the
whole world economy the whole of it
the whole uh effecting the whole world
economy the
everything that's happening in the world
there's a kind of uncertainty in which
we're all living
and and that kind of pulls this fog in
front of our eyes
and therefore we might be distracted
from
paying attention to what it would mean
to for our own career right
so here is a quick thought as you speak
today as you responded to those
questions what's your role and how
you're feeling today
in the current situation in your own
life what
is the fog you are facing quickly take a
minute leave some comments in the chat
and and i'll quickly browse through it
and we can continue with our story
what's your fault
in your life in the current situation
what
am i chasing a moving target current job
role somebody says
age lack of skills for a dream job
future uncertainty of future somebody
says
change in market conditions keeping up
with competition knowledge
somebody says knowledge is the fog for
them
don't know what my current job what's
the future prospect of my current job
decision making hectic situations
experience career growth
laziness procrastination learning
agility there you go peace
wow thank you all really really
great pandemic pandemic became a fox
with somebody because you lost your job
uh domain age time management project
delays
changing requirements work pressures
thank you all i mean that's really
really brilliant thank you all for being
vulnerable open
so let's stay with the fog the the first
thing to do with the fog is
acceptable accept it acknowledge it and
then see how we could overcome
more responses are coming through uh
procrastination so and so forth so
so let's stay with the start of the fog
and now let's see how
you know how is this fork manifesting in
all of our lives in different ways
let's see so um
you know this graph is picked from the
book um
written by thomas friedman it's called
thank you for being late and it's an
interesting craft because it shows
how technology has been growing
exponentially using the technology curve
exponentially
growing up and human ability to adapt to
it
which is almost like a 45 degrees or
slightly
you know lower slope of curve now what's
very interesting is when you look at
this graph
rate of change versus time as humanity
as humans where it did
very interesting juncture with the
technology which we all created is
actually growing at an exponential rate
and we
for the first time in the history of
humanity are playing the catch-up game
so we're at the interesting tip of the
diamond you could see the diamond
where we are and the sooner we can play
the catch-up game
we can learn faster and govern uh
smarter that's when we can catch up with
technology or else it's going to be
difficult that's one digital fog or
digital blur which we all are facing
so so because of this rapid change in
technology
and the need for us to adapt quickly
it leads to certain circumstances and
let's see what those are
the first one very interesting again
since 2000 seems like yesterday it's
actually two decades ago
uh more than 50 percent of fortune 500
companies
no longer exist imagine fortune 500 are
some of the best organizations in the
world
they no longer exist because of the
upshooting technology
we have new business models coming in
new new channels in which we deal with
our
clients and customers different new
organizations and new ways of doing
things
and therefore even some of the best
organizations out there couldn't play
the catch-up game and therefore
they lost in the whole race so so that
you know that's another frog they had to
deal with and they kind of
dealt it in a bad way and that's a
challenge we all are facing
collectively and individually now i
would like to in next
couple of minutes you know bring bring
some of your perspective to
a report published very recently in the
month of october
by world economic forum the report is
titled
uh future of jobs 2020. some of you
would have seen it but this report has
a lot of implications for for each one
of us
doesn't matter which our industry and
we're really excited to see people from
various industries on today's call doing
various jobs in today's call
so here are some highlights you know
it's a very detailed report i would
highly recommend each one of you to go
to world economic forum's website and
spend time on
the future of jobs reports i'll give you
a couple of glimpse and some imperatives
so so this feature of jobs report
published in the month of october last
month
projects how the workplace of the future
five years from now would be and here
are six imperatives i wanted to bring to
all of your notice
and with the simplicities we'll start
digging deeper
the first imperative accelerated
technology adoption
the technology was always going in a
faster rate thanks to fourth
industrial revolution and after kobe
what happened was
digital transformation became a big
priority for most ceos and cxos
and therefore uh there's an accelerated
native nature in which
technology is getting adopted the
because of which some of the
technologies which are highly in demand
are
cloud big data e-commerce
also uh other topics which are catching
up quickly are
encryption ai and non-human art reports
on the rise so so that
that side of technologies is playing a
quick catch-up game so that's an
imperative for you to think over
second one automation and rpa was always
a big focus but because because of
kovaid it kind of double disrupted the
whole
realm of automation many cxos if you
read the report
uh from world economic forum and other
reports talk about how they're trying to
automate most of the business processes
and and replace
part of their human workforce with
machines
and again by 2025 the estimation by this
report is
the current job roles current tasks and
activities which
humans are playing at workplace 50
of that would be either automated or by
taken over by machines another
only 50 percent would be left for humans
so automation is actually
double disrupted second big
international imperative to keep in mind
the third one jobs of tomorrow and this
is again a very interesting
insight so the way technology is
shifting we're going to displace some
existing jobs
there's some jobs in the current
workforce globally
which will no longer exist in the future
thanks to automation and technology
adoption
and because of technology shaping up
there new jobs which will be created and
those are called
uh new role emerging jobs so the
estimate for next
five years is there'll be 85 million
jobs globally which will be displaced
and replaced and 97 million jobs
which will emerge which are new and
we'll see what those are as we go
and then uh that's good news right 97
million is more than 85 million
having said that the problem is the
imperative for when you look at
imperative iv
there's a huge skill gap with the
existing workforce
in organizations uh you know at least 40
percent of workforce globally
in existing organizations need minimum
six months
or around six months of reskilling time
so i'm not talking about days training
or a two-day training or a week-long
training i'm talking about
six weeks of training imagine how much
amount of effort you need to kind of
bring bring about that reskilling and
there are also new skill gaps in in the
student
uh you know the students coming from
from colleges and universities
also have a skill gap so these two put
together creates a very interesting
gap in the overall talent ecosystem
that's the fourth imperative
the fifth imperative as as technology is
getting disrupted kovit caused its own
disruption
everyone is impacted but if you don't do
a good job there's a very high chance
that um
younger workforce women workforce or
even
workforce with age might might face some
situations of inequality so i'm going to
keep an eye on that too as we go
and then the last piece is as all this
is happening in accelerated way
the window of opportunity to re-skill
and upskill all
all of us is getting shorter and shorter
so it's really important
so so forget about the 85 million
displaced jobs even those roles which
are not displaced
uh even the roles which stay forty
percent of the roles are changing which
means they need to be
reskilled and retrained and and at least
fifty percent of employees
all all the companies which took the
service say needs reskilling so
look at this six imperatives together
we're talking about next couple of years
in the horizon the amount of shift which
is happening and that's going to create
a lot of interesting challenges but also
a lot of interesting opportunities so
with this
with this imperatives i'm going to take
you further deeper into some of the
uh you know insights right here let's go
to the next slide
yeah so um
so here is an interesting one so all of
you currently in the workforce and
i saw many of you you know they were not
finished the couple of
uh you know significant part of your
students but those who are currently
already in the workforce
this is an interesting slide for you
what this slide tells you is
uh you know when you look at the horizon
from now till 2025
which technologies will be adopted the
most forget of the industry will come
back to industry later when you go to
the report you will see the industry but
irrespective of the industry these are
the technologies which are getting
adopted the most cloud computing big
data
iot encryption aiml text image and voice
processing
e-commerce and digital trade and if you
see
uh uh compared to 2018 and 2025
difference there's a huge uh you know
upward progression in most of these
technologies so
so these are the areas in which they're
going to be significant
opportunity to rescan up skills so
irrespective of
whichever domain industry you are keep
an eye on these technologies so you
could say
you know i'm from a manufacturing
background i work in a manufacturing
industry i work in a
pharma industry how does this what does
this mean to me
for example if you work in a pharma
industry you need to keep an eye on how
can big data analytics
change the business model of pharma so
how can you apply the technology of big
data in the use case of pharma
and that could be an interesting mix so
you know we all need to ground
ground ourselves in our foundations and
still pick on this additional skills
irrespective of the domains you
represent so it's not just for
those in iit industries it's it's
universal so
that's a big uh insight for existing
workforce
to see which technologies are getting
implemented across industries
across domains obviously uh between
various industries they'll be very
you know the duration of adoption will
be different but still overall you know
the top
uh implementations and that will kind of
drive your approach
you know you could start thinking of
your entry skilling up skilling journey
now this is this is another fascinating
infographic from the same report and and
this is this has a
lot of covet influence to it but still
very fascinating so the way to read the
report is all the young workforce who
were
pre-covered six months before eight
months before and year before
were working in those six industries on
the left
higher education restaurants retail food
and beverages entertainment and
hospitality
because of the disruption of korea
they're actually displacing themselves
into new industries
and you can see the new industries on
the right hand side hospitality and
healthcare
financial services i.t and services
education management
not for profit management so and and
what's helping them
make the displacement are the roles you
see in the center so
so they are picking their existing
experience existing
uh knowledge and you know
learning these new roles to displace
into the right hand side so
so those of you who are students on the
call here is
you know insight for you in terms of how
the younger workforce
have started displacing themselves
across industries because of the korean
effect
and that will give an insight of which
industries
will have you know we saw the
technologies will be implemented in that
just like but this slide talks about
which industries will have
most opportunities from a you know a
career perspective so again a very
interesting
insight the second comes from world
economic forum that's the second insight
i wanted to share with you
now the third one this is again very
interesting and and i saw many of you
from project management background many
of you from engineering background
healthcare pharma various backgrounds
and you might be thinking how do i
how do i deal with the fog of how do i
you know in this in this new era of
technology
what happens to my job how do i
transition
this image again from world economic
firm 2020 report
has those insights for you the way to
read the report is if you look at
data and ai what it says is uh
people who will transition into data ai
roles uh
the dark blue band is people who grew in
the same room
they'll continue they were trained in
the same role they stay in the same room
the light brew the light blue brand is
people who are in
same job cluster so they had some
experience in ai
or data but if you see the entire peach
pan
are people moving into data and ai
from other job clusters other unrelated
job clusters so what it's meaning is
there's so many we saw in the first
slide that there are quite a few job
openings in in this new technologies
like cloud big data
analytics uh you know humanoid and and
aiml right and and e-commerce now what
we're saying is
to fill those job roles people will grow
in the same job clusters as you've seen
in the dark and the light blue shades
but since there are enough openings and
then these roles are easy to
adapt from other industry almost 50
percent or more
of workforce in these roles will come
from other
other job clusters other job families so
some of you sitting on
the conversation today saying hey i
don't have an experience in data and i
am a project manager
this is what it says you could
potentially move to
a you know data and ai track or cloud
computing track
product management time so there's
there's a need
there is acceptance that you could make
this career shifts
obviously you need a bit of training and
learning will come to that piece around
upskilling and reskilling but this shows
what are those occupations and job
clusters of the future
which which are actually open to taking
people from other job clusters and
occupations so it should give you
some interesting insights as you're
planning your own future for yourself
so that's the third insight i wanted to
change
the fourth one is in the same report um
world economic forum they talk about
what are the top 15 skills of 2025
and as i talked to this slides i want
each one of you to pay complete
attention to these
items from 1 to 15 and and
i'll read them out for you but as i'm
reading them out please process it with
me
analytical thinking and innovation
active learning and learning strategies
complex problem solving critical
thinking and analysis
creativity originality and initiative
leadership and social influence
technology use monitor and control
technology designing and programming
resilience stress tolerance and
flexibility reasoning problem-solving
ideation
emotional intelligence troubleshooting
and user experience
service orientation systems analysis and
persuasion and negotiation
you know as you heard me speak and look
at those 15
tech top skills of future for 2025
it's actually quite surprising right
most of us would have thought there'd be
a lot of technology things written there
there are only two
or three technology things seven and
eight technology use monitor technology
designing and programming
and there's a bit of trouble shooting
which is 12 and
14 is more systems thinking so so what's
interesting is as we're moving
as most of the motor skills kind of jobs
for humans
are getting automated the higher
cognition the higher decision making
functions
are the kind of jobs which will be which
will stay with humans
therefore there is a dire need to be
successful in that kind of future
this entire need to have better
cognitive skills
better problem solving skills
better service orientation better
leadership skills
better emotional intelligence and if you
see item number nine
resilience stress tolerance and
flexibility came out of
kovit all of us went through that right
and and i want
all of you to pay special attention to
number two
active learning and learning strategies
things are going to change so fast and
they'll continue to change so fast
what will keep you at the top of your
game is your ability to learn
learn quickly and have unique learning
strategies to keep learning
so a big takeaway headline for me is the
skills of future are less of technical
technology is important but beyond
technologies cognitive skills emotional
skills
higher order problem solving skills
higher order relationship skills like
emotional intelligence
and higher order self management skills
like resilience
so on so forth you see critical thinking
complex problem solving
creativity originality initiative that's
what's going to drive
all the roles you saw the earlier slides
so again a big take away
you could quickly do a you know brain
math and brain assessment of where you
think you are against these skills
and how can you build these skills for
yourself for the future
so that was my fourth imperative now uh
you know putting it all together
this is a nice two by two grade by
mckinsey and and the way to read is
x-axis is existing and new jobs y-axis
is human and digital skills
so the four quadrants being in existing
jobs we need human skills and obviously
it's very
obvious with with the way technology is
shifting these jobs are going to get
displaced so the bottom left corner
jobs are getting displaced and moving up
to all the three
quadrants now if you move up existing
job digital skills
is area where you know rpa automation
kind of things are happening where
new work is done uh new technology is
applied in the old job
you know that's where it's uh you know
uh
left cord left side top quadrant if you
move right
new jobs human skills is where
human skills are taught to people and
you saw the earlier side that quite a
few human skills which are taught to
people so uh one example you know the
meteorological department in australia
did this huge project so they're like
around 1000 to 1200 members
and the job was very easy you know
they're the weather department in
australia so the job was
to these people living across in
australia i lived in australia for a
while so i know
how vast the continent can be the job is
at a certain time of the day
go uh open up the uh weather balloons
launch them into the atmosphere and it
will collect some readings
come back down bring it back home it's a
very physical kind of a work so what
they did they worked with
as an automation operations and they are
committed the whole thing
to robotics you know robo started
displacing all this
you know uh the job of taking the
weather balloons in various weather
conditions morning evening night
even in central whatsoever it can get
really hot so and the biggest fear
everybody had was
if you're going to use robots for all
this work are we going to lose jobs
you know should we send the people who
got home but long story short after they
implemented what they found was
all the people who were doing the
weather well kind of a job
they got higher order jobs where they
started working in the office
taking phone calls doing custom service
calls with citizens
talking to them giving them feedback so
nobody lost their jobs just the nature
of their jobs
increased that's the right hand quarter
new jobs
human skills that's what technology
would do now if you look at the
top and right quadrant is digital skills
required to steer clear
to create share and maintain technology
and newly created itc jobs that's the
area of
of pre-scaling so if you have to look at
this
uh uh left top quadrant is the area of
upskilling
bottom right is also area of upskilling
uh but there's a bit of human reskilling
and then
uh right hand top corner is where you
have real
skilling happening so various types of
skilling and and
generally the way we use this terms are
in the existing technology new way of
doing things or
incremental learning is called
upskilling you know you take a java
programmer train them on
data and ai then that's reskilling and
then you know that's how you kind of
read those four definitions one two
three four
now what's very interesting to read is
uh
something called meta skilling since
things are changing so much and you saw
in the earlier slide
skill number two learning and advanced
learning technologies
so meta skilling the best way to define
this are
life lifelong habits enable individuals
to
develop new mindset embracing life long
learning
and other overarching life skills so the
way things are have been happening for a
while
a couple of meta skilling uh skill areas
which all of should
all of us should be adapting to is
learning agility ability to learn things
faster
emotional intelligence because things
are changing so much
and then agile ability to work in a
child way so i would say
learning agility
just walking things in a very agile and
iterative way and also
emotional intelligence are like three
lifelong skills which will help you
irrespective with your career with your
job
with your function or domain you you
work in
so so so those are some of the insights
i wanted to share with all of you
from how technology is shifting all this
right and in fact to summarize
if i quickly jog your memory and do
quick headlines
six imperatives technology is
accelerating automation is getting
disrupted
uh jobs are getting displaced new jobs
are getting created but there's a huge
skill gap
inequality could get affected and then
the window of opportunity to re-skill up
skill is very short so we need to act
quickly
then people currently in in in workforce
this is where these are the technologies
which are getting implemented as we
speak
irrespective of domains and functions
and then people who are students getting
into workforce
this is where younger workforce used to
work a while back but they are moving
into
new industries so that's a sense it
gives you how
which way the industries are shifting
for younger workforce you're going to
enter
workforce soon then um
you know the the new technology areas
which are open to
accept people from various occupations
and job clusters data and ai cloud
computing product development people and
culture
as you can see market interestingly even
sales sales function is open to
invite people from other other
backgrounds so so
you know those of you wanted to make
make a changes
risk killing up skilling here is a good
good indicator you should definitely
read the report more but again good
insight and then the top 15 skills
needed for 2025 the big headline is
technology is not the answer the answer
is higher order problem solving skills
higher order self management and higher
order relationship and emotional
intelligence
is the need of the future therefore
summarizing apart from picking skills
along the way skilling and upscaling
each one of us need to pick certain meta
skills
which will set you up for success not
just today but future
three metaskills i can think of is self
awareness and emotional intelligence
learning ability and thirdly
ability to work in a very agile way are
three
beta skills which will help you
throughout your career
that's a big headline so so if that was
a summary
you know taking leave from alice in the
wonderland book
i know there's the famous point in the
story where
alice walks into the the forest and
there's a
there's a tree and there's a fork in the
road one road goes left one would goes
slight and alice
is stuck there and she looks at the top
of the tree there's cheshire crack
cat sitting there right on the tree and
alice asks this question
which george should i take and cheshire
cat
is supposed to be wise looks at uh
alison says depends on where you want to
go and then if you read the book or
watch the movie
then alice says i don't know
where i want to go then the cat replies
then it doesn't matter take any of the
roads it will lead you there
hey i want all of you to ponder over the
conversation between alice and the cat
so if you don't know
where you are going any road will lead
you there because
you don't have a goal you don't have a
name you don't have a direction it
doesn't matter
so that's the question yeah there's a
lot happening
in the industry a lot of shifts lot of
transformation a lot of changes
but the question is do you know where
you want to go
you know that's that's where i would
like to start and take little deeper
yeah we saw how the whole world external
world is changing girls but
if i have to make this journey and and
if you go back to the topic of today's
session
the lots of words say there's a word
called future
there's a word called upskilling we
explain that there's a word called
reskilling
we explain that we looked at a glimpse
into the future
now i'm coming to the world called
career
now if you go back and look at the topic
of today's session it didn't say
reskilling upskilling strategies for
your job
it said reskilling and upskilling
strategies for your career
career is not job career is more longer
term care is based on your goals
your aspiration your dreams your values
your purpose your mission
job gives you financial security gives
you money but career gives you a lot
more than that the question is
do you know what career you want to make
and then you saw the glimpses of the
future which i gave you till now
but once you are clear about your own
career and your passion on your career
you can look at all the insights from
technology from the future
and then start planning planning your
own career
so here is the cheshire cat analysis
moment for you to
ask yourself do you know where you want
to go
that's one of my biggest questions for
you and as you're pondering over that
i'm i
want to leave you with five strategies
of how to answer this question and
probably also
set yourself on the journey of
re-skilling and upskilling
so strategy number one know your values
your individual core values and
strengths that's the first way to get
started on the journey
i would highly recommend all of you go
to this website called
via character.org and later when you do
that i'll try to post this link in the
chat via character.org
and there's a free assessment when you
take the free assessment you know
you get a report of your top five
personal values
i have taken this assessment i got
introduced to this code value assessment
almost
a decade back and from then i used the
results from my values
in every decision and choice i've made
so that's really really
important so i would highly recommend
you do that also to understand what are
your strengths at the workplace
uh there's a beautiful assessment from
gallup called strength finder
you could go to gallup's website take
the assessment it's a paid assessment
or you could buy gallup's book the book
is called strength finder 2.0
if you buy the book the paperback
edition in india you get the access code
at the back of the book and
with the access code you can take your
own strength assistant i would highly
recommend
you taking your gallop strength
assessment because with these two
you know your foundations if you know
your core values you are able to
articulate your
values and you know what are your work
strengths
that place your formulation that's
helping us figuring out
where she wants to go and what she wants
to do so that's my first strategy for
you
know your values and know your strengths
strategy number two
uh going back to the skill number two
learning strategies
active learning strategies you know how
can you be at the top of your game and
build a lifelong meta skill of being a
learner
be an agile learner the solution
lies in being curious can you be curious
with the following three things can you
be curious about yourself what's
happening inside your own emotional
awareness
emotional intelligence can you be
curious about the world around you
why is the world the way it is learn
more about it question it
ponder over it and can you also be
curious about people around
those are the three facets of building
curiosity
and curiosity as a skill will help you
build learning agility
and it will lead to a lifelong meta
skill again to understand where you are
today
in your sense of curiosity i invite you
to take this assessment from global
curiosity institute it's a free
assessment
i took a uh you know they launched it
recently very recently just couple of
weeks back
i took my own assessment and i got a
very fascinating report of eight to ten
pages of
how i how curious am i with the world
around me
how curious i am with people around me
and finally and most importantly how
curious am i about my own self
my own thoughts feelings and emotions
and that builds my sense of learning
absolutely so i would i can invite you
all of you to take this assessment to
build this
sense of curiosity to build the skills
of the future 2025.
moving to strategy number three you know
where you are
you know your current role and you saw
how technology shifting all the insights
i gave you from
the world atomic forum report and then
by the time you arrive at strategy
number three you already would have
done your strategy number one which is
identifying your core values
knowing your strengths and then
identifying how good are you in
curiosity so assuming you do all that at
this stage
in the sequence of things in the
sequence in the same
chronological order i would recommend
all of you to then
with all the information you have sit
down and do a swot analysis
so what is a simple problem solving
analysis which helps you
choose between one or more choices what
are my strengths in a given situation
what are my weaknesses what are my
opportunities and what are my threads
you do this analysis and then you are
able to make score
the options you have so i would highly
recommend each one of you sit down
and go through these questions what are
my career strengths what are my career
weaknesses
what are my career opportunities and
what are my career threats
and do one do an overall overall outlook
of your thought analysis
and then based on what analysis great
outputs
options you have for yourself if you
just do a simple google search and how
to do a swot analysis
you will get hundreds of hits very good
resources which will help you to walk
through these four stages but very very
intuitive process but highly
reflective in the nature so i would
highly recommend after doing
all that i've done so far strategy one
and two you sit
and do a career swap to see what career
options you have
and the time frame i would want you to
keep in mind is
next two to three years next two to
three years is the time frame
but beyond that um i would definitely
recommend that strategy three
doing a swat analysis now uh
strategy number four this is again been
my own personal learning
and it kind of accentuated and increased
after coverage happened almost
seven or eight months back i always had
a mentor a mentor for her life who has
been mentoring me for
almost a decade and you know whatever
career i've made great choices i've made
the career progress i've made attribute
most of my success and lessons
learned to my my life mentor has you
know mentored me
career choices and life choices uh
having said that the biggest lesson i
learned from kobe was
sometimes that but not enough there's so
much happening in the kobe time from uh
you know we use that on vuca world where
things are very volatile and certain
ambiguous
so on so forth so i had to move
beyond having just one mentor to create
a network of mentors and coaches for
myself and as i speak
i worked with the series of peers people
in same industry different industry
people who can mentor me respect of the
religion and troll and designation
people who can coach me
at one point just one or two months back
i was personally getting close with
three coaches together we formed a small
whatsapp group
on the whatsapp app and they were all
coaching me on a work situation i had so
so again a big takeaway for me the way
things are shifting we need to be really
agile
and the big paradigm shift for me is to
move from
trying to solve problems with my own
experience to
a paradigm of trying to solve problems
collectively with everyone's experience
and learning
so i alone cannot solve the problems i
need inputs and insights from everybody
else
that's been a big paradigm for me so i'm
going to invite all of you to do the
same
start chatting out who could be those
mentors and coaches in your life
personal side
professional all the aspects of life
financial doesn't matter
make a list of those people and stay
close to them spend time with them
you know they could be your peers they
could be somebody who can play a role of
a quote somebody who can really
play role of a mentor and that's why the
image on the right hand side the biggest
question
is on this slide i want to leave all of
you with this
if your
career was a company if your career is
an organization
who would be on the board of your career
who are the board of directors of your
career and one of the actions i would
suggest all of you to do is after this
call sit down and think if your career
was an organization who would be on its
board and list down the names of people
and those are your
network of mentors and coaches then
approach them take their permission
uh you know seek their support to help
them with the decisions
also other invitations i'll make all of
you do is in your respective
current profession you're working on the
future profession you have aspiration
with
identify those communities of practice
and be
part of those communities could be on
linkedin could be on whatsapp could be
on
greatest learning platforms we have
numerous learning platforms now
open source platforms and all the
platforms identify these communities of
practices
and be part of it so create a network of
medicine coaches for you
that's when you'll be able to move
towards your dream career in a very
accelerated way
and if you see the last bullet i said
give and take there's a famous book
uh by adam grant on the same topic given
take i would highly recommend if you
haven't read the book
read through the book to understand the
nuance of what i'm saying but
it all starts by giving or also equally
receiving
and it's all starts with identifying
who's on your board of directors
your career code of directors could even
be your life board of directors
start from there so to summarize all of
this
i would come to strategy number five if
you do
all that then you can build
the most important skill the meta skill
of being
a learning individual and that's what
matters than anything else
the way the whole industry in technology
is setting doesn't matter which
domain you are part of which
professional part of
your age uh which culture you come from
which organizations you know
future lies with individuals who can be
learning individuals
so build that muscle of learning agility
so to highly recommend
as you saw the technology side of things
uh the next five years which
technologies are going to
uh you know be in the mainstream
maybe your top skill yourself in some of
those topics maybe you want to rescale
yourself in some of those topics
and maybe you also want to learn some of
the higher order thinking skills higher
order emotional tension skills
all the top five skills we saw in the
earlier slide so whatever it is could be
technology
which could be adopting some of these
emerging skills could be those
uh you know higher order thinking skills
decision making skills emotional
intelligence
create a plan for yourself so i would
highly recommend the way things are
changing
create a quarterly plan and that's what
i've been working for myself at least
for the last one or two years i
i always have a quarterly learning goal
a 90-day learning goal
work on it and move on and do another
quarterly learning goal so this quarter
i have two learning goals
i'm actually doing the uh a course on
learning how to learn it's a book
published by
dr barbara okay and i'm currently going
through that course and book
and also i'm going to record some life
coaching skills so that's my
this is what is going and i'm already
planning what to learn in the next
quarter coming up
so plan 90 day quarterly goals
uh plug in your reskinning up skill
needs plug in the technology
needs plug in the you know needs from
higher order thinking skills problem
solving
emotional intelligence so on so forth
and for
for all of these skills that numerous
opportunities
learning avenues platforms digital
online platforms free
paid you know it well you know you you
just google you'll find them so i'll
i'll not go there but but idea is to
create learning as a habit
make a 90-day learning plan could be
reskilling up skilling
and see how those learning plans align
to your own unique experience and
strengths
and where would that come from that
comes from your swot analysis so so by
by the time you reach to strategy five
you should run your swot analysis
then proactively find learning
opportunities not just on the job
outside job with your mentors with your
coaches with your peers
with your board of directors with your
communities of practice
could be a job could be outside job then
then the most important piece
is focus on not just learning knowledge
but actually practice
do hands-on practice so so for a simple
example in aid of data and ai there's
so much of free data sets available on
the google if you just
google them up there hundreds of people
who are experts and influencers
posting their thoughts and comments on
twitter linkedin
with you know hundreds of data sets all
you have to do is learn technology
and then take those data sets and
practice so so move beyond knowledge to
practice
and then that's where your your network
of mentors and coaches and communities
of practice will again help you
implement it i would highly recommend
and stay informed of industry trends be
it
reports published by nascom in india
reports published
the lord recently published a report on
the deloitte millennial report
and then world economic forum you know
the report i've been referring to
published the jobs of the future 2020s
to stay close to these
industry uh you know
thinking bodies and then stay close to
the trends and then
plan your ninety that's right keep it
really agile 90 day goals not more than
that 90 day learning goals
please killing up skilling 12 weeks
sprints run it as a spend
run your own life as a sprint and by
doing all that you build learning
agility
and that's the most important meta skill
which will help you deal with
uh the way future is shaping with the
first section of the presentation we saw
and that's the only way for you to rise
above the fog
and going back to the story we started
with of of florence uh
chadwick it was a fog
her inability to see the end goal which
which made her give up so by building
these meta skills of being
an agile learner and applying these five
strategies
you can rise about the fog which you
currently have in your personal and
professional life
or rise above the future for which you
might face in terms of uncertainties
and create a career and a life which is
future proof
that's what i wanted to cover hopefully
it gave you some insights and thoughts
about the way things
are shaping up now i would like to turn
it out is too much
and before i do that a quick summarizing
uh on your own career on your
development and be a lifelong learner
now i'll turn it on the store to um you
know
do some q a and as we're doing that
wrapping up with this code
the iterate of the 21st century will not
be those who cannot read or write
but those who cannot learn and learn and
learn and that's the challenge for all
of us
you anna
good thing for us to all to remember
as we um that's so
yeah um
and let me take back the presenter
yeah sure definitely yeah okay
i'd like to thank um i know for joining
us today
um it's been a great session um how do
people get in touch with you
yeah i actually it wasn't like if i
could quickly
share my screen for a minute
i'll do um um yes let me do that in just
a moment here
yeah let's just give me a second
good thank you
yeah there you go just quickly doing
them do it in a minute
um i'm sharing my screen can you see it
yes yes so uh
that's the best way to reach out to me
that's my email id but if you have your
mobile phones
if you would quickly put your mobile
phone and scan the qr code
that's my linkedin profile page
you can correct me or linkedin and then
we could stay connected
always write to me my email id right
there
so we wish to leave it there for 30 more
seconds so people could
then then you can take back the
presenter rights here
i was involved in the company that did a
digital visual code similar to a qr code
i never would have guessed that one of
the applications would be putting the
code on a screen
so that people with another device could
scan the screen
that's true i mean these are different
ways in which we can adapt
you know technology right for example
when when i
run webinars in my organization we
actually put a qr code for
feedback service now so people just scan
the qr code and fill the feedback survey
in the end so
a lot of interesting applications
through the qr code yeah
thank you uh we're gonna steal that idea
yeah you can
yeah it's not it's not my original idea
so
[Music]
and again thank you and i want to also
thank
freshers world uh which is part of the
team these group of companies and it's a
number one job portal for pressures in
india
and it's sister concerned team lease
is a leading portal for entry-level jobs
and gig jobs
blue collar jobs and so these are great
career resources for some of the people
in our audience today
so we thank them for their sponsorship
and
like to let everybody know about our
next webinar
which will be wednesday of next week on
december 2nd
9pm ist which is 10 30 a.m
on the east coast of the of north
america
powering linkedin big data through open
source technologies
with assange rajawani of
linkedin who is
one of their directors of software
development and it will be
an excellent session for people who are
interested in software development
careers
and you can also connect with simplyline
we'll have to add our own qr code there
um
but we are on facebook twitter and
linkedin
and we are worldwide so
wherever you are we would love to hear
from you
and help you with uh your ongoing
upskilling
and continuing learning needs
so that concludes our webinar and
uh thank you all for being here today
we will be sending out a link to this
recording
um and for those of you who have been
with us this far
you will be getting a certificate of
proof of attendance um
which will allow you to prove to your
employer or
your school that you have been paying
attention to
your ongoing education needs so thanks
again
thank you thanks everyone
you